Okay, so we know how to calculate the volume of a box if we know the length, the
width and the height of the box. So let's take another look at how Athena was
folding her boxes. She'd take a piece of paper like this one. Then she would
measure a square in each corner of her rectangular piece of paper. Then she cut
the squares out of the corners. And then she would fold up the edges. And tada,
with a little bit tape we'd have a pretty nicely put together box. So we know
then we can make box out of a piece of paper that looks like this. It once was a
rectangle until I cut the squares out of the corners. Let's draw that on here.
So here is a nice little piece of paper for us to start out with. And then I can
draw this to show what it would look like after the corners have been cut out of
it. Awesome. Now, on the real piece of paper that I was using, this one, the
original side length of this long side was seven inches. And the original side
length of the shorter side was five inches. So let's pretend like this paper has
the same dimensions. So the orginal side length was five inches. And this
original side length down here was seven inches. Now, Athena and I are both
super careful people, so we made sure that the squares that I cut out of each
corner are exactly the same size. That means that each of these lengths of a
cutout square is the same. Let's call that length x. Now, I'm going to give you
a second to refresh your memory on how this box looks when we fold up the sides.
So here's my real one again. This length is x. This is seven inches and this is
five inches. When I fold it up, it looks like this. We have length, width, and
height. Now, my question for you is, once I fold up this box, what will the
height of the box be? Please put your answer in this box. And just a hint, it
may not just be a number.